[Musique]
squeeze regarde où on en est à cause de
toi franchement je voulais pas le faire
mais tu me laisses pas trop le choix
quand je t'ai connu c'était sympa et
grand comme ça aujourd'hui tu es devenu
arrogant mais tu es toujours grand comme
ça tu le sais qu'à chez quelqu'un c'est
pas ma première fois ma dernière cible a
disparu du net alors davance pardonne
moi franchement à ta place je ferai pas
le malin parce qu attelage tu as encore
besoin de moi quand tu déménager faire
du bricolage je préfère faire des bulles
sur du travail pas du racolage hérédité
truqueurs ferme tu te retrouves au
chômage je reconnais tes la star dans
les cours de récré entre deux parties
dit les enfants discuter leurs préférés
et mon petit doigt me dit qu'il va
encore grimper car ils vont bien tourner
et achêne sur les télés dans les
maternités
qu'importe la place pour les gens je
reste premier dans leur coeur si tard et
que dire des serais-tu tomberait dans
les profondeurs
constate fière d'avoir des millions de
vues au compteur si le seul majeur qui
mate et vidéo c'est un menteur
bottes cacher
c'est la cour
d
[Musique]
pas de clash mais
c
grandir ça te ferait du bien on dit la
chaire humain qui a besoin d'amour est
ce que tu as vraiment devant expliquer
ma place de numéro un pour te sentir
bien c'est quoi ces techniques de mégalo
tâches et à tête en jouant dans métro
annoncé la ratp oui à la station où vous
ne devenez pas suffisant s'achever des
vidéos depuis longtemps mais pour
arriver au même résultat j'ai fait qu'on
voit qu'une vidéo toi 1200 youtube money
to see a viz even qu'on suspecte
pyramide c'est la vérité tu t'en métrage
est une 1ère chance chante avec moi
lâche mai
c'est la course
s'il reste
d'attaché
m
la place
pas de cash le
c
la cour
les enfants
la place